so grip strength is extremely important
for your overall performance and even
your health it's been linked to
mortality rates but here's something
that perhaps you didn't know about grip
strength that much of it come from your
little finger it's logical and
understandable to assume that when it
comes to grip strength vigor must be
better that the index finger and the
thumb must contribute the massive
proportion of grip strength and that
your little finger probably doesn't
really do much in fact though this
couldn't be further from the truth by
gripping onto a rope as though you're
going to climb it and use just the top
two fingers you'll find that it's really
hard to get a stable enough grip to
really hold on now try through the same
thing with the little finger and the
thumb and you'll find you have a much
more secure grip one study found that
when measuring grip strength via a hand
dynamometer the ulnar digits were
responsible for 34 to 67 percent of grip
strength with the mean average being 55%
this is something was actually well
known by the East Samurai and apparently
if the samurai betrayed their master
what would then happen as punishment is
that they'd have their little finger cut
off this might seem odd with the samurai
knew that by removing the little finger
they'd be able to very effectively
impair the samurais ability to fight
with a sword it'll be much easier to
knock it out of their hands with a
well-timed blow so why is this well the
owners digits are controlled by a
separate muscle called the flexor carpi
ulnaris and the ulnar nerve but that
power and your little finger isn't
available in an isolation just using
your little finger you won't be able to
exert that much strength and that's
because the little finger gets most of
its power by working in tandem with the
other fingers the second fingers we've
discussed and also the thumb think about
it we call them opposing thumbs what do
they oppose well the most opposite
2-digit is the little finger and by
clenching them together we're able to
make a nice closed circle remove either
one of those and you have a weak link if
you try performing pull-ups with your
little fingers sticking up in the air
you're going to find that a lot more
difficult now try doing the same thing
with your index finger sticking up in
the air and you'll find it's actually
not as difficult another interesting bit
of information is that the strength that
the little finger contributes is
disproportionately greater on the
dominant hand than it is on the
non-dominant hand what's going on there
though is anybody's guess so what do we
do with all this information well the
obvious thing to consider is just that
we need to train our little fingers and
it's actually very easy to overlook this
if you're using a grip trainer for
instance and squeezing you might find
that the angle of
grip train it makes it easy it's a
little finger to play a much smaller
role so make sure you're not doing that
and consciously make sure to contract
that little finger likewise if you're
using fat gripz or just squeezing the
bow was performing other movements
really involve the little finger really
make sure that it too is playing a part
it also tells us it's really not too
good to injure the little finger so look
after it make sure you don't bend it
backwards when playing sports and if you
do give it ample time to recover and
don't lift anything too heavy over your
head whilst you're in that condition
you're much more likely to drop it on
your face what's more is that you should
really think about the position of your
grip when training meaning the way that
you use your thumb and fingers together
in particular wrapping your thumb back
around and over your fingers when
lifting weights or hanging from rings or
a bar will help you bring your wrist and
pinky into a stronger position simply
changing the position of a single finger
moving the knuckle of your pinky finger
on top of the bar during a pull-up for
instance you can meanwhile alter the
muscles primarily being worked in this
case you're adding flexion to the wrist
and you're increasing your lats
activation likewise when you train the
farmers walk try bringing the pinky
knuckle under the handle of the weight
to again increase flexion in the wrist
this will train the grip more
effectively than if you give no thought
to the position of the fingers and the
wrists training wrist flexion this way
is actually incredibly valuable when it
comes to preventing injury but make sure
you're training with both a supplemented
and a pronated grip as well as a neutral
grip to avoid imbalances which can
actually make things worse and if you
build this up you'll find that things
like rope climbs and muscle ups become
much easier and far less likely to snap
your arms off so you go guys that was
just a small little tip I hope found it
useful and interesting if you did then
please leave like please comment down
below helps me out immensely do you have
any quick tips to share about grip I've
got much more on the way of course more
quick tips like this one lots more
in-depth videos looking at things like
va2 max and lung capacity coming very
soon balance training polymath series on
the way so for that sounds good then
thanks a ton for watching and I'll see
you next time bye for now
[Music]